一定要学会走结尽 永远想办法去寻找更省立的方法
就过去我们有一些错误的理解
就是走结尽这件事一定是错的
然后简单的事
你订为那么重要
正确的方式 一定是费实费利
要非常 非常辛苦的
但是我们又想过
那些有价值得特别重要的事
其实可以用很简单的方式去完成
我们之所以用很复的方式
是因为我们没有找到更简单的方法
给RFN想三个我自己的轻身案例
然后美党案例的话还有别的意思
拿我第一张的你来说吧
大概是10年前
然后我偶尔会出去做一些分享
然后莫我打个场 就是要给你的大场
然后有一次请我去做分享
就莫个专业领域
一天
然后为了做这个分享
就提前一个月节奥去做准备
然后在分享之前的每周都每天晚上
我们要一个一个一个对那些东西可以讲的
一东西不应该讲的
然后一个怎么样做
为什么呢 因为参加这个会议的
是打场的各个失业群的老总
就他们的时间当不起
所以而是非常为什么人人
这一场分享下来给我累了脱了一层匹
等着后来的话呢
一个我来的机会
然后有一个机构情绪做分享
当时现场大概有一千多人
然后问他讲什么
说你就给大分构最继续的东西好了
给大一些最继续的入门的东西
就可以了
因为来的人的话他们其实是没有多少继续的
其实那个事情对我来说就很简单
因为我在这个联名带的很长时间
给大一些很继续入门的东西都是很简单的
结果分享完以后
这个大家的反馈都偷温背得好
而且我的收益其实皮我给那个打卡场还多
这件事给了一个很有意思起发
就是我们过去一直想努力地向上提供假设
叫就学成文武一或卖地文家嘛
就是一定要努力努力努力的话上卖卖的更高的效果
但是其实有些时候你不需要那么努力
一直需要把自己的一些经验分享
给刚刚入门人
你也可以过得很轻松
且可以获得不错的收益
所以这个阿里其实是有两层意思的
我希望你能听到
然后第二个部分的话呢
就是假的阿里是什么是上个视频
我估计很久没理解
其实我每天做的工作非常少
就是每天去干什么
我给大家去过很小的意思啊
就是我每天
就真的是看大家对我什么呢
去求那些去求是值得研究的
那些问题是值得解决的
然后我就想办法解决
你当时不可能马上就提供一个解决吧
所以有些时候只是一个想法
然后那个想法
我会把他卸成一段文字
就是每天卸点什么
这段文字有些时候会把他发到社群里
有些时候会把他发到小策子里
但是你会发现这段文字后来可能会变成一个小策子
会变成一本输货的变成一个产品
然后货子收益拿去投资
然后其实每天要做的事情
明明是一样就是每天卸点什么
但是我的收益非常好
而且给这个社会的辣椒子也非常高
所以各位你看有些事情可以用很简单的方式去完成
然后我们来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来来來来来来来聊聊
三打的
就是发生今天的攻击案例
因为每周末的时候
我们有的时候其实我在那边呗
然后我看到看到好的方法
就是这个问题
他大家的问题
我来来大家解决
就我们发现
我看到好的方法
我就是在拍的还是评结的时候
拍不下去就是没有
没有内容框拍
然后也有柳俑量也不要这个做
然后突然获得一个灵感
这个灵感是什么呢
就是
你知道我以前是程序员
就是我那时候用抓把用塞砂把写网站
写过往这大概需要两三周的时间
整理一个月的时间才能把这个东西做好
因为要写出去过程
还得有很多技术吧
但是后来的这个转件
好像也里面出现一个人
叫大避换的行程
他住了做了个框架叫书饼
然后就是
您可以
用很简单的方式就是一天之内就可以把一个往这上一个往这
就做了非常非常简单
方而是就是把一些最基本的东西
他也帮你提供你只要做就可以了
哇这个给我的体会的特别深
就是一个很符打的问题
可以用很简单的方式完成
所以说这个你们起发呢
我今天又合所的了合意
体内很简单方法说
OK我们把几个压缩压缩压缩压缩
就三个不凡拿三个部分
就是
一开始咱们吸引用
第1个部分就直接给担护
第3个就进去
如果这个东西是干落的话
对别人就夹实
只要对别人就夹实就一定可以活得关注
对吧
然后进去的话就是总结
所以这个内容一定对别人有帮助就会有关注就会有做差
但是如果你前面能够吸引
能把用后吸引起来
那么其实就会有
三秒的帮过率啊就会有
播放的市场啊这个数据的话呢
就可以不错
一开始就可以上手可以一看
有些事情可以用很简单的方式去完成
所以各位
一定要学会走解进
就在做一件事情是的时候之前想一想
这个事有没有有一种更简单的方法
帮我去完成呢
这多想一想就对我
就可以提升我们打到的这里
你会有更多的想法而且有些时候
你真的可以
早到一些
就是你这需要付出一点点
等着留说没点些点
你就会有我的很大很大的
收益
可以
永远要选择最省利的方式
学会
走
解调